wir sind endlich zurück aus der
sommerpause und während sich die briten
ab heute an charles den dritten gewöhnen
schenkt uns olaf der erste schon wieder
ein entlastungspaket sehr wahrscheinlich
nicht das letzte von den machern von
entlastungspaket 1 und entlastungspaket
2 kommt nun entlastungspaket 3 jetzt
wird's wuchtig
65 milliarden bauen die mal eben so raus
zu recht zu rechnen die rezession kratzt
schon an der tür da kommt quasi auf jede
minute an
haben wir können die zeit zu warten
wir eben jetzt geht's ab freunde der
scholzomat wirft den turbo an diese
woche hat er sich im bundestag ein
regelrechtes schrei gefecht mit
friedrich merz geliefert über die
aufregende frage ob die union oder die
spd mehr schuld hat an der gas
abhängigkeit von russland eine gut uns
bürger bewegen eigentlich andere fragen
eher banale dinge wie kann ich nächsten
monat noch alle rechnungen bezahlen aber
hey emotionen müssen halt auch mal raus
ansonsten fordert unser kanzler dass wir
als gesellschaft jetzt was noch mal dass
wir uns unterhalten er sich lange
unterhalten uns unterhaken und daten
unterhaken untergehakt sehr viel
untergehakt sehr sehr untergehakt
unterhaken unterhaken unterhaken unter
zu hacken und harken die unterhalten
unterhaken und unterhaken dass wir das
machen wozu eine solche spargelfahrt
ganz besonders gut geeignet ist dass wir
nämlich uns unterhalten
ganz genau olaf scholz und sein
berühmter linker unterhaken aber
schauen wir uns das paket das uns
geschenkt wurde dieses paket 3 noch mal
genauer an also da sind natürlich
natürlich auch jede menge gute sachen
drin also 18 euro mehr kindergeld zum
beispiel höheres wohngeld
steuerentlastung und jetzt kommt der
hammer auch die vergessenen der letzten
pakete kriegen diesmal war es ab zum
einen studierende als werden dass
plötzlich auch menschen
und sie hier sie profitieren zuerst vom
neuen entlastungspaket ab september
bekommen rentner einmalig 300 euro
da eskaliert der speisesaal ja er ist
typisch rentner alles direkt für
aufputschmittel verballert
leider gibt es zu den 65 milliarden so
toll sie klingen schon noch ein paar ja
ungeklärte detailfragen zb wo kommt das
geld her
32 milliarden spendiert wohl der bund
irgendwas zwischen 15 und 19 hoffentlich
die länder was die verdutzten
ministerpräsidenten aus den nachrichten
erfahren haben und dann werden für die
strompreis bremse so genannte zufalls
gewinne abgeschöpft ja es ist ganz was
neues
ja wie genau das aber funktionieren
sollen mit den zufalls gewinnen weiß
zufällig noch keiner herzlich willkommen
zu unserem neuen quiz zum
entlastungspaket
[Musik]
sehr gute frage ok ich sag mal was ich
verstanden habe zufalls gewinne sind
gewinne von kraftwerksbetreibern die
nicht mit teurem gas arbeiten aber
denselben hohen preis kassieren das wäre
dann ein eingriff in den europäischen
strommarkt aber selbst wenn das klappen
sollte wie viel geld soll denn dabei
konkret rumkommen aber wenn dort solche
zufalls über gewinne im großen maßstab
anfang haben wir viele viele viele
milliarden um sie den bürgerinnen
bürgern zurückzugeben
verstehen viele viele viele milliarden
werden das schön quizfrage was wäre
viele viele viele umgerechnet in euro
könnte jetzt eine zahl nennen mache das
nicht weil das ein stück spekulation
enthält ja ein einfaches weiß ich nicht
hätte es auch getan
so falls abschöpfung können wir nicht
stattdessen eine echte über gewinn
steuer absetzen zb für mineralölkonzerne
die in diesem jahr wahrscheinlich allein
in deutschland 38 milliarden über gewinn
machen werden wäre das nicht eine
alternative
nein
schade
die strompreis bremse ist erstmal eine
luftbuchung sorry wie hoch ist der
sogenannte basistarif in dem der strom
erst mal günstiger bleibt was kostet der
tarif gilt er befristet oder unbefristet
ist alles noch offen und was wenn euch
das ganze in brüssel rechtlich um die
ohren fliegt was sagt er denn dann den
bürgern schönen
schuss das war
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier
so sieht im moment noch das konzept für
die strompreis bremse aus wissen sie
noch wie damals wenn man seine
hausaufgaben im bus gemacht hat dabei
drängt die zeit und die insolvenzwelle
rollt längst den schuhverkäufer görtz
hat's erwischt und auch die
energieintensive klopapier industrie
gerät ins schlingern hakle feucht ist
pleite kein witz leute
wir sind am arsch
und viele maßnahmen greifen erst in
monaten beispiel hartz 4 empfänger
kriegen zwar demnächst bürgergeld und
damit 50 euro mehr aber eben erst im
nächsten jahr ja genau wie die
überfällige wohngeldreform wie bitte
sollen die menschen bis dahin ihre
rechnung bezahlen die bundesregierung
bittet um ihre mithilfe liebe hartz 4
empfänger sie fragen sich wie sie bei
den lebensmittelpreisen durch herbst und
winter kommen sollen machen sie es doch
einfach wie bären winterschlaf ganz
genau überwachen bis zum bürgergeld
jetzt noch schnell vergriffen anfressen
solange der dollar noch unter zehn euro
kostet sich schön zu zweit in einen
schlafsack trommeln und den wecker auf
märz stellen wer bis frühling durch rats
spart heizkosten und verpasst die
sklaven wm in katar die weihnachts folge
vom traumschiff die neujahrs folge vom
traumschiff die rückkehr der masken
pflicht die rückkehr der abschaffung der
massen pflicht sowie die neuen corona
varianten monika und manfred in diesem
sinne gute nacht deutschland ihr
verpasst nichts
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich nicht
winterschlaf
oder andere idee wir senken endlich die
mehrwertsteuer auf lebensmittel
der staat hat dank inflation allein
durch die mehrwertsteuer im ersten
halbjahr anschneiden 29 milliarden mehr
eingenommen verstehen sie christian
lindner ist der größte zufalls gewinner
von allen ja bei dem müsste man mal was
abschöpfen
aber okay sein wir fair die ampel steht
im multi krisenmodus vor fast unlösbaren
aufgaben und sie gibt ja wirklich alles
um den menschen mut zu machen selbst
wenn es ganz eng wird kommende
wahrscheinlich durch den winter
jetzt fühle ich mich schon viel besser
ja
natürlich bade die arme ampel jetzt in
der energiepolitik die fehler von
jahrzehnten aus das gilt auch für robert
habeck persönlich neulich noch sie
erinnern sich super populärer kanzler
der herzen jetzt so was wie der watsch'n
august vom dienst naja ist ja so zum
atomstreit kamen diese woche noch der
spott über seine wissenslücken in sachen
insolvenz bei frau maischberger nicht
völlig zu unrecht muss ich sagen denn
speziell pleite bedrohte kleine
bäckereien die im moment eben kaum
staatliche hilfen kriegen fühlten sich
da latent verarscht klarer fall für den
vertrauenslehrer
90 stunden nachsitzen bayern ass gleicht
heute die wl so was bist du ja wieder
willkommen zurück selber schuld ich habe
es dir tausendmal gesagt wenn du zu frau
maischberger in die prüfung gehst musst
du dich vorbereiten google mal
vorbereiten weißt du was das ist
vorbereiten ja niedlich gucken nutzt ja
auch nix ich weiß mit dem blick hast du
dich damals bis zum abitur gemogelt
angebetet vom weiblichen lehrkörper auch
das sind 7 aber die nummer zieht bei mir
nicht freunden das war eine super
einfache frage von der kollegin patti
einfach aber rechnen sie mit einer
insolvenzwelle am ende dieses sind das
nein das tue ich nicht ich kann mir
vorstellen dass
bestimmte branchen
[Musik]
einfach erst mal aufhören zu produzieren
dann sind die nicht insolvent
automatisch aber sie hören vielleicht
auch zu verkaufen
was ist denn das für eine logik schatz
ich geh nicht fremd ich habe nur auf
gehört dir treu zu sein wenn ein
geschäft nichts mehr produziert um
nichts mehr verkauft aber weiter kosten
hat dann ist das geld von dem geschäft
bald alle obert bis zu das ist klausur
relevant du träumst doch schon wieder
das sehe ich doch genau wegen der
einstellung vermurkst du nämlich jene
gas umlage und hör auf mit den doofen
ausreden weil wir aber nicht wussten das
muss man ehrlicherweise sagen und
niemand wusste dass wie dieser gasmarkt
verflochten ist
niemand wusste dass deine
bundesnetzagentur wusste dass meine
fresse das kannst du im mündlichen alles
nicht mehr ausgleichen
weißt du inzwischen wenigstens wie die
pendlerpauschale
funktioniert das wolltest du doch über
die sommerferien nachholen die
pendlerpauschale wird aber auch bezahlt
wenn man bahn fährt ja aber nicht dann
ist es ja nur die erstattung des
bahntickets und die oder wird sie dann
das weiß ich kann ich aber die
entscheidende frage ist die
entscheidende frage ist warum hast du
dir ausgerechnet das
wirtschaftsministerium ausgesucht du
hast doch deine starten junge so im
ganzen lagerbereich wird doch minister
für keine ahnung poesie und vedes
streicheln oder so kommt ist gut für
heute deine mutter kann dich abholen ich
habe hier noch einen anderen nachsitzer
hier dieser schulhof schläger der
ständig fordert woanders voll gefragt
werden aber nicht bei ihm
da sitzt der vogel ja markus höher auf
schon wieder himmel aus voll zu kritzeln
während ich mir die rede ich weiß doch
genau was du da machst
90 kunden bank sitzen bayern ass gleicht
nachsitzen bayern hassknecht
als strafe der herbst ist da freunde und
er wird heiß das höre ich jedenfalls
jeden tag im fernsehen erst kriegen wir
wohl einen heißen herbst und direkt
anschließend kommt der sogenannte wut
winter ja befeuert von medien die sich
gerne gruseln auch schon vorab und von
leuten wie sahra wagenknecht und
so
surreal und berechtigt die ängste vor
inflation und jobverlust natürlich sind
so erbärmlich ist es daraus politisch
kapital zu schlagen vor allem wenn man
dabei aus versehen dieselben slogans
benutzt wie die afd die afg die
alternative für russland sie wissen
schon und auch und auch wir beim
fernsehen sag ich mal selbstkritisch
müssen aufpassen je öfter man wut winter
sagt desto sicherer kommt an der ampel
steht ja absehbar herbst bevor dass wir
einen heißen herbst bekommen von heißen
herbst an heißen herbst heißen herbst
wut winter dem winter der wut weil wir
dann mit volksaufständen beschäftigt
sind und wir soziale unruhen kriegen
sozialen sprengstoff
volksaufstände kann was sich in nummer
kleiner
wenn 300 opas mit trillerpfeife sind
doch kein aufstand
4000 demonstranten letzten montag in
leipzig übrigens auch nicht deutsche
politiker warnen fast schon vor dem ende
unserer demokratie beim menschen von
ihrem demonstrationsrecht gebrauch
machen und je öfter man die alle
sprachlich in die nähe von extremisten
oder umstürzen rückt desto mehr zulauf
kriegen die demos die antwort kann nur
lauten bessere sozialpolitik statt angst
vorm eigenen bürger wobei man vor
einzelnen bürgern natürlich angst
kriegen kann wenn die menschen wieder
auf die straße gehen werden sie den
schießbefehl erteilen wird die polizei
die jetzt hier steht gegen die
bevölkerung eingesetzt
und wann werde ich endlich ins heim
gebracht
können sie mich da hinfahren herr wurden
das kanzleramt
kritik immer gern da lebe ich quasi auch
von das geht ja auch ohne sich zu putins
propagandamittel zu machen wie zb die
afd
ich habe keine ahnung ob die inzwischen
vom kreml bezahlt werden aber verdient
hätten sie es auf jeden fall robert
habeck wirtschaftskrieg denen er
gegenüber russland erklärt hat trifft
uns alle uns allen deutschen hier in
unserem land ja ja ja unvergessen der
schlimme tag als robert habeck damals
ganz allein und unprovoziert in russland
einmarschiert ist ne warte mal ist nicht
putin die ukraine hfd und teile der
linkspartei fordern jetzt verhandlungen
mit russland über gaslieferungen mit
anderen worten wir sollen beim
kriegsverbrecher um gas betteln warum
hält uns der putin los für schwach man
versteht es nicht und selbst aus dem
bürgerlichen lager kommen seltsame
vorschläge von michael kretschmer und
wolfgang kubicki zum beispiel
großes thema im sommer
kretschmann forderte ein einfrieren des
konflikts also eine top idee einfach
wegducken und ein frierenden kriegen
wenn wir den jetzt 1 gegen krebs meinte
putin 20 prozent der ukraine im sack und
kubicki immer in vizepräsident des
bundestages will nord stream zwei öffnen
wieder andere fordern endlich
verhandlungen mit putin obwohl der gar
nicht verhandeln will also wenn ich so
darüber nachdenke vielleicht wird dieser
herbst doch ein festival der schlechten
laune
diesen herbst wird heiß beim blüten
ssten outdoor festival des jahres
bist du fit genug für
dann hol dir jetzt ein ticket und
freudig stinkwütend auf alle mega stars
der szene kilo ich bin stocksauer kubala
fanpaket jepsen und als fesche guest dj
knoxville 2 mit seiner mit aus meinem
ohr kommt immer gas und natürlich bernd
das brot vergleich dazu thüringer
bratwurst russischen gas gebrüllt
wegen des großen besucheransturms wird
sogar ein zweites dixi-klo aufgestellt
dann doch lieber helene fischer
trotz des erp bereich
ist mir schon klar natürlich ist die
versuchung groß zu sagen in diesen tagen
das ist ja nicht unser krieg das stimmt
aber gar nicht putin hat uns allen schon
vor jahren einen hybriden krieg erklärt
der arbeitet aktiv an der zerstörung der
eu und selbstverständlich verteidigt die
ukraine auch unsere freiheit während
herr putin die wahre bedrohung diese
woche ganz woanders verortet ich meine
damit dass sanktions flieger des westens
und dessen aggressive versuche anderen
staaten verhalten aufzuzwingen sie ihrer
souveränität zu berauben und seinem
willen zu unterwerfen
sagt der mann der gerade ins nachbarland
einmarschiert ist und grenzen als
unverbindlichen vorschlag betrachtet
trotzdem gibt es deutsche in diesen
tagen die sind wütende auf die ampel als
auch putin nein er hat uns das gas
abgestellt wie war noch die letzte
ausrede von gazprom ein ölleck an einer
kabel steckverbindung natürlich
natürlich als nächstes sagt gazprom
wahrscheinlich steht ihnen total leid
aber sie wussten nicht mehr in welche
richtung der gashahn auf oder zugeht
dann gibt's ein marder schaden in der
schaltzentrale und am schluss schüttet
gerd schröder versehentlich zwölf bier
ins kontroll puls alte schüssel ich sage
wir müssen stadt und zweiter mit
turbinen und öllecks verarschen zu
lassen endlich von uns aus alle
russischen rohstoffe abbestellen
das resultat wer exakt dasselbe also
kein gas aber wir hätten ein stück
unserer würde zurück der winter reden
wir drüber mit einem der
ungewöhnlichsten menschen der welt mit
olaf schubert schön dass du da bist olaf
olaf auf demos argumentieren viele
einfach aufhören mit sanktionen dann
wird alles wieder gut sind heizkosten
wichtiger als freiheit und wie viel
entbehrung kann man den deutschen heute
überhaupt noch zu
das ist natürlich schwierig sage ich
meine freiheit gegen gegen heizkosten
abzuwägen ja also ich meine wenn du
jeden monat 500 euro schulden machen
muss dann fühlt man sich ja auch nicht
so direkt frei also looks die kröte klar
aber kosten den frosch also jetzt so als
metapher und ich denke mal so die die
entbehrung das ist ja ja das ist er so
ein generationenproblem ja also ich
meine unsere generation wir wieder so
wird deutschland aufgebaut nach dem
krieg also
wir beide ja genau der war krank also
wir haben ja quasi
stein für stein übereinander ja ich bin
jeden tag fünf kilometer barfuß auf
arbeit durch den schnee ja sagen wie
winters und und die generation die jetzt
kommt diese blut lernen milch fertigen
schlaffi sie hatte die wollen wirklich
balance die wollen ja partikel die
wollten quality time
sonnenverbrannte kurze ja ich meine
müssen sie hingegen wegen elektrosmog
und wieder aufstehen wegen
hausstaubmilben ja also ich meine
wenn bei dieser generation
hatte winter realität wenn der unter der
yogamatte durch zeit also dann
die heben ab da können wir uns ein haken
wir wollen ja dass
er einige leute auch wütend macht wir
sprechen über wut in diesen tagen was
auch wütend macht sind diese
energiespartipps von politikern du weißt
schon duschen statt baden oder natürlich
der inzwischen legendäre waschlappen des
grünen winfried kretschmann wie findest
du diese tipps
also ich muss sagen ist also ich finde
es ja erstmal beruhigen das grünen sich
überhaupt was also
mittlerweile scheinbar und
wahrscheinlich bloß mit kompost abreiben
und ich finde das schon sage ich mal wie
hilfreich einige mögen das ja arrogant
finden oder aber ich meine das ging ja
schon an mit ursula van der leyen als
sie in der korona pandemie erklärte wie
man sich die hände wäscht nämlich mit
wasser und seife ja ja ja das war für
mich so ein aha effekt ja also ich hab
das ja jahrelang gemacht irgendwie mit
spiritus und sind
und dann jetzt sozusagen die nächste
stufe der waschlappen und ich kann mir
das dann auch bildlich immer gleich sehr
gut vorstellen ja herr kretschmann wie
führt er den waschlappen tja so
was muss ich im schambereich beachten ja
das ist ja eine sehr sensible zone und
ich finde diese form der intimität baut
auch so die diese diese klüfte ab ich
finde dadurch werden die politiker für
mich auch wieder menschen nähern also
wenn ich jetzt hier von olaf scholz weiß
was benutzt ja von der hornhaut raspel
beispiel zum beispiel wie stehst du zu
aktuellen atomdebatte länger laufen
lassen oder nicht manche wollen ja sogar
neue akw s was meinst du also das hat ja
die eu selber gesagt sie hat er gesagt
atomstrom ist umweltfreundlich und ich
gehe es natürlich davon aus dass die
grüne akw bauen so an wie sie es machen
weiß ich nicht vermutlich haben sie dann
als brennstäbe opera und irgendwie gut
gekühlt mit gurken wasser
aber es wäre nicht ungefährlich das wäre
gut da kannst du das ding gleich in die
stadt rein bauen ja wenn es explodiert
das einzige was freigesetzt wird ist
blütenstaub also aber die aktuellere
frage lautet ja wie verhindert man die
blackouts ja da haben wir jetzt zwei
atomkraftwerke in standby das klingt gut
aber es hat sich herausgestellt die
brauchen eine woche zum hochfahren also
um hochzufahren die wirklich eine woche
hat ja sowieso ein rentner uni blogger
und ich meine
also denn nach einer woche stromausfall
hat man sich daran gewöhnt
dann sitzt man in der höhle dann hat man
sie schon so den pelz über die ohren
gezogen man hat den ersten luft gerissen
man sucht die partnerin ab nach mäusen
so und und plötzlich rum ist der strom
wieder da also dass das wäre mir zu
hektisch also dann
angebote aus olaf schubert vielen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
oh gott der dreh für die nk